selon certains c'est pas le 50e
anniversaire du premier pas sur la lune
qu'on commémore c'est le 50e
anniversaire de la plus grande
supercherie de l'histoire certains vont
essayer de le prouver en regardant les
photos en prenant les choses simplement
et sur les photos il ya effectivement
des choses étonnantes par exemple vous
avez un ciel noir sans aucune étoile et
on les décorateurs de hollywood ils ont
pas été très bon là dessus en réalité
c'est parce que c'est le jour lunaire et
il y à la nuit par l'apparence de la
nuit et beaucoup de lumière parce que
c'est le jour en fait et les étoiles ne
sont pas du coup visible parce que la
photo en fait est prise par la lumière
et les petites lumières qui seraient les
étoiles on les voit quasiment pas ou pas
du tout même
ensuite certains disent mais on nous sur
une des photos on voit buzz aldrin et on
voit à travers enfin on se reflète sur
son sur son casque neil amstrong qui
soi-disant prend la photo mais on ne
voit pas prendre la photo à la raison en
fait c'est parce que l'appareil il est
intégré à sa combinaison et on le voit
il appuie là puisque effectivement c'est
par là que ça se passe
mais surtout l'essentiel c'est le
drapeau ça c'est le grand truc le
drapeau flotte sur la photo or il n'y a
pas d'atmosphère sur la lune
il n'y a pas de vent le drapeau devrait
tomber
et bien c'est précisément parce qu'il ne
voulait pas que le drapeau tombe que les
américains avaient installé une tige sur
le haut du drapeau pour qu'il reste bien
droit vous allez me dire aux amis
dallaire il est un peu froissé alors ça
les astronautes explique que c'est parce
qu'il a été pliée pendant le voyage
on la déplier dont il y avait encore les
traces des plis et il est la tige du
coup le drapeau ne flotte pas mais
effectivement on a vraiment l'impression
qu'il flotte qu intéressant c'est que
cette rumeur
elle n'est pas née immédiatement
franchement le 20 juillet 1969
pour les américains le lendemain matin
avec le décalage horaire pour les
français il n'ya pas de doute le demi
milliard de téléspectateurs et
absolument ébahi par ce qu'il voit et
c'est en fait quelques années plus tard
dans les années 1970 combat que c'est
temps peu mais certains vont commencer à
douter
chacun première événement intéressant
c'est 1971 il ya un james bond qui sort
les diamants sont éternels et dans les
diamants sont éternels
il ya une scène où vous avez james bond
qui arrive sur un plateau de cinéma qui
reconstitue les pas du premier homme sur
la lune dans le james bond on ne dit pas
tout ça est bidon médian ce 10 mai et si
tout ça était pas fait sur 1 sur 1 sur
un plateau de cinéma
la petite graine de la rumeur commence
éventuellement à naître à ce moment là
et puis surtout le début des années 70
c'est une période de très grands
mensonges de la part des plus hautes
autorités américaines
cette même année 71 il ya la révélation
dans la presse d pentagone papers les
pentagon papers film un film de
spielberg est pas longtemps là dessus
c'est la révélation des mensonges
américain pour le déclenchement de la
guerre au vietnam
et puis trois ans plus tard c'est
watergate
le président nixon a menti aux
américains et démissionne pour cela et
donc dans ce contexte dans ce moment de
mensonges officiels
mais pourquoi pas ce mensonge là
d'autant plus que les américains avaient
quand même un immense intérêt à être
avant les soviétiques sur la lune dans
la guerre froide à ce moment là certains
sont même allés loin en disant très dans
le détail c'est une mise en scène
inventé par stanley kubrick que brick
qui vient de réaliser
juste avant l'arrivée de l'homme sur la
lune 2001 odyssée de l'espace
il sait faire puisque manifestement il a
fait un film là-dessus donc 10 fr ce qui
est marrant c'est qu'il ya un cinéaste
français william carrère qui il ya
quelques années s'est amusé avec cette
rumeur et a fait ce qu'il appelle un
documenteur pas un documentaire un
documenteur et dans ce docu menteur en
fait il fait comme si tout était une
supercherie et il fait comme s'il
racontait le tournage en studio par
kubrick du premier homme sur la lune
donc il a tout mis en scène et cetera il
monte c'est un film hyper bien fait et
ce qui est génial dans son film c'est
qu'ils interviewent beaucoup de témoins
de l'époque sans leur dire qu'il fait un
documenteur donc les gens raconte la
vraie histoire mais lui avec le montage
et c'est là que ça dit des choses sur la
force
montage avec le montage il fait dire ce
qu'ils veulent et aujourd'hui encore le
montage peut faire dire n'importe quoi à
n'importe qui beaucoup diffuse notamment
un bout d'extraits de buzz aldrin qui
avouerait qu aucun homme n'est jamais
allé sur la lune
il n'a jamais dit cela mais en coupant
ses mots et c'est pas encore du dip fait
qu'on n'est pas encore en train
d'inventer des propos dans la bouche des
gens en faisant juste du montage on peut
faire dire un peu un peu ce qu'on veut à
n'importe qui là par exemple on pourrait
complètement monter dans tout ce que je
viens de vous raconter et me faire dire
qu'aucun homme n'a jamais marché sur la
lune
ce qui n'est manifestement pas le cas en
tout cas à en croire les dénégations de
la nasa
des dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
d'ingénieurs de scientifiques y ont
travaillé sur le projet et du
gouvernement américain